all right so i guess it was a few days
ago now
um the website stronger by science
an article went up by our very own greg
knuckles
the article was called the evidence is
lacking for effective reps
and as we've done on the show previously
one of the cool things about the podcast
is that after we publish an article on
the site we have an opportunity to see
what the feedback is like
and the podcast gives us a great
opportunity to
clarify things discuss kind of how
people receive the article
any questions that came up from from
readers
so we do want to take some time to talk
about this article so
before we get into that greg can you
explain
what the general concept of effective
reps is
yeah so the the nugget of the idea
behind
effective reps is basically
for for a rep of an exercise to promote
hypertrophy
it needs to be close enough to failure
that it's kind of hard
um and and the reason for that is
basically
a lot of the mechanistic work looking at
what
kicks off muscle protein synthesis and
hypertrophy
shows that like you need
it shows that one your highest threshold
motor units are probably the ones that
are
the most susceptible to hypertrophy and
so
they're not going to be recruited unless
a load is adequately heavy
or until you're close enough to failure
so
um an implication of hitman's size
principle which is just like a very
foundational
aspect of muscle physiology is that
as loads increase more and more motor
units are recruited
and then also with lighter loads if you
take them to failure for the first few
reps
most of just like lower threshold motor
units will be recruited
and then as they start fatiguing and you
get closer and closer to failure
more and more of your high threshold
motor units will eventually be recruited
so
you know either doing reps with heavy
weight or doing
lighter weight all the way to failure
both of those things will eventually
recruit all of your motor units
so the idea being that until you get
pretty close to failure
you probably haven't really tapped into
those highest threshold motor units
and then the other thing is most of the
at least best characterized
physiological pathways that initiate
muscle protein synthesis and hypertrophy
uh are related to muscular tension in
some way shape or form so
essentially there's um
there's little things uh there's
spots where the muscle fiber is attached
to
the um like connective tissue matrix
that
surrounds each muscle fiber and also
runs through the muscle
and it seems like a lot of the actual
like molecular pathways that
eventually trigger muscle protein
synthesis have a lot to do with those
little adhesion points
and when tension is put on the fiber and
it kind of pulls on those
adhesion points that uh activates like
various kinases that
then trigger the processes that
eventually lead to muscle protein
synthesis
so those are our tension based processes
so the idea is you need to both recruit
motor units and then also expose those
fibers to enough tension
that it's going to to kick off all of
the
hypertrophy cascade and the
the notion here is that with
with weights that aren't like super
heavy so weights that aren't like five
rep max or below
you're probably not recruiting all of
your motor units from the first rep
and you can probably move each rep
pretty quickly
and when you're moving a rep pretty
quickly um
you you don't have enough time to form
enough actin myosin cross bridges within
each fiber for there to be a ton of
tension
on the fiber so basically like if you're
grinding
a one rep max or if you're doing like
something plyometric
you're probably recruiting all or most
of your motor units for both of those
two things
but there's way more tension when you're
doing the one rep max because
the plyometric is very explosive the
shortening velocity
is high there's just not that much time
for too many cross bridges to form
to create tension which is why like
you know if you grind out several sets
of tin to failure you grow quite a bit
you do some jumps you don't grow all
that much um
so so that's kind of the idea like the
kernel of the idea behind
effective reps you need to recruit those
high threshold motor units
and you need to to get movement velocity
low enough that each fiber can be
exposed to
a whole lot of tension the idea some
people have is
to maximize tension uh on each fiber
which they
propose will will occur right before
failure
and this idea has uh gotten a lot of
traction right like you did a little
poll on your instagram the other day
basically saying like essentially the
question was like how
favorably do you view this effective
reps idea was that essentially what you
asked
yes so the original poll i think had two
options
one was it's legit and the other is it's
bogus
and then like a bunch of people message
me it's like oh
it's probably more complicated than that
it's like dude you can only give two
[ __ ]
options for an instagram poll like calm
down
uh so then i added another like slide to
my instagram story that says like you
can also interpret this as like
mostly correct or like mostly incorrect
and i added that within like
30 minutes of the poll going up but
anyway so like 2500 people voted in that
and it was like 62 in favor of
effective reps being a valid model and
38
against and and so there's um
there's various like quite a few people
have have put forward
various ideas for effective reps um
chris beardsley's model is probably the
most well known so that's what
my article was critiquing but james
krieger has
put forth a similar idea carl juneau and
i'm going to butcher his name but i
think you pronounce it
borje but everyone
calls him borge because i think
no one knows how to pronounce his name
we're not the people to ask about it
anyway um so they've all put forth
various uh effective reps esque concepts
but
chris beardsley's idea is the one that
has gotten the most traction
and it is essentially the idea that the
last
five reps before failure are the ones
that are effective
those are the ones where basically all
of the motor units have been recruited
and there's going to be enough tension
per fiber to to trigger hypertrophy
um and he's he
has spelled it out in such a way that
at least makes it seem that each one of
those five
would be similarly effective so um
he's like gone through like different
scenarios like oh if you do
you know four sets to failure or four
sets one rep shy of failure
four sets two reps shy of failure like
this is how many effective reps you
would get
and that very much makes it seem like
it's not like
oh maybe the rep before failure is the
one that's actually the most effective
and like
the one five reps out is a little
effective but not
as close like it's it's a pretty
straightforward model where basically if
it's
within five reps of failure it counts if
it's more than five reps out it doesn't
count um
so like an implication of that is if you
did
four reps or if you did four sets to
failure that would get you
four more effective reps than four sets
one rep shy of failure you'd get 20
effective reps
uh so the last five of each set if you
did four sets to failure
you'd only get 16 effective reps or the
last four of each set
if you did four sets one rep shy of
failure
so not another implication there is if
you
you know kind of do traditional strength
training where you know
you're probably terminating most sets
two to three reps shy of failure
then you would probably need to do eight
sets to get the same
hypertrophic effect as four sets to
failure
so just kind of throwing some some
concrete implications of the model out
there
um and so
the thing about this concept of
effective reps
is it has some degree of mechanistic
support
um so for example if you look at
research
where like people are doing
isometric exercise at different
percentages of
of maximum voluntary isometric
contraction
it seems like working up to about 80 85
of mvic that's like the range in which
motor unit recruitment does increase
and past about 80 or so most of the
further increase in force
just has to do with increases in motor
unit firing rates
um and there's also some research
looking at
surface emg for single joint exercises
finding that when you get about five ish
reps from failure for single joint
exercises
emg plateaus and you don't get further
increases in emg as you get closer to
failure
so emg isn't
it's not like one to one the same thing
as motor unit recruitment but
the two things do correlate reasonably
well
and there's also
like direct evidence showing that you do
need pretty slow contraction speeds
to maximize per fiber tension
essentially because
the rate at which uh actin myosin
detachment can occur is um
like pretty variable but the rate at
which attachment or
the rate at which detachment can occur
is pretty variable but the rate that
attachment can occur is fixed and
reasonably low
and so with really high fiber shortening
velocities you get
uh like fiber detachment rates can
exceed attachment rates so only like a
fairly small
percentage of your like actin and myosin
cross bridges
potential are actually forming but with
slower contraction velocities the
attachment and detachment rates
can match up better and so you can get
much higher
for per fiber tension um
so anyway that that's the mechanistic
idea there is
mechanistic evidence uh underlying that
and there is also some degree of
experimental evidence to back this up
so the two studies that i think most
people would cite
as evidence for the concept of effective
reps
is one back from like 2004 2005 by goto
at all
and then a more recent one by martarelli
and colleagues
and so in the goto study basically you
had two groups
doing four sets of ten one of the group
was taking those sets to failure and the
other
group was taking like a 30 second break
between reps five and six of each set
and so with that 30 second intra set
break
they weren't taking each set to failure
because they were getting a little bit
of rest in between
and in that study they were doing knee
extensions and they were measuring quad
growth
and they found that the group uh doing
those four
doing those 10 reps straight through
without the break in the middle
did grow considerably more it was like
two and a half times more
and then in the more recent martarelli
study um
untrained women were doing bicep curls
at 70
of their max one group was doing three
sets to failure one group was doing
three sets of seven which would probably
be
five or six ish reps from failure and
one group was doing
four sets of seven which was like trying
to match volume load with the three sets
to failure group
um do you think seven is the least
common number of reps to prescribe
i feel like in the history of lifting
i've never heard of someone being like
give me a good seven here i don't see
many fours either
oh i do fours all the time i don't think
that many people do force don't talk to
my clients
i see a lot of heavy triples and then of
course
five yeah but yeah don't see too many
fours
i i do fours all the time but sevens are
off the table i would never dare
prescribe a seven sure um
but anyway so in in the martyrelli study
the
the increase in biceps thickness i think
was like 18 and a half percent
in the failure group uh like eight and a
half percent
in the four sets of seven group and like
two percent
in the three sets of seven group so
pretty big difference there
um so that's kind of like the evidence
in favor of this effective reps model um
but there
are problems with it so the research
show the research suggesting increased
motor unit recruitment
up to about 80 85 percent of one rep max
or about five reps shy of failure most
of that
is looking at single joint exercises
and you can also find it some with like
multi-joint exercises with untrained
lifters
but there's actually several studies
using trained lifters
doing multi-joint exercises finding that
the prime movers
might be pretty close to full motor unit
recruitment at considerably lower loads
further from failure
so there was a recent study by vandyn
tillar
and colleagues looking at the squat and
it was looking
at quadriceps so i think
every head of the quads except for the
vastus intermedius it was looking at
quadricep
hamstring and glute emg
with increasing loads and found that
with loads between like
50 and 90 of one rep max
uh for like the first rep of each set
quad emg was the same
um so and there's actually modeling
research by
uh brianton and colleagues um
using a measure called relative muscular
effort which is
essentially the the external moments
presented by an exercise
divided by the joint moments
kind of measured in a single joint way
that lifters can produce
like in isolation and so that study
found that relative muscular
effort in the squat basically didn't
change with increased loads
and and so that does actually seem to
match with
uh with emg as well and so also in that
study it looked
again at hamstring and glute emg and it
did see that those were going up with
increased load
and so the quads are probably
if you had to choose one prime mover in
the squat it is probably the quads
and so the prime mover pretty high emg
from the get-go
some of the like secondary supporting
muscles increase dmg as load goes up
uh similar with uh an older study by
mcbride and colleagues
uh it looked at quad and hamstring emg
with uh 70 80 and 90 loads
it found that quad emg at 70 pretty much
the same as 90
um but hamstring emg again was much
higher at 90
than 70 so again prime mover emg
pretty high even at fairly low loads
like 70 is
reasonably low um but a secondary muscle
in that case the hamstrings
ramping up as load increases uh and then
there was also a study from a couple
years
back by kroll and golus looking at
increasing loads in the bench press
and it found that pec emg also
basically the same between uh 70
one rep max loads and actual one rep max
loads
but the emg of the front delts
triceps and maybe lats
also did go up with increasing loads so
again
if you had to pick a prime mover in the
bench press it's probably going to be
the pecs
uh don't tell louis i said that um
but this the secondary muscles your
triceps front delts
those emg is going up as loads increase
so it very well could be that kind of
first assumption of the effective reps
model that
you do need for recruitment and you need
to go pretty close to failure or pretty
heavy loads to get that full recruitment
i i think that is very much true with
single joint exercises but i'm not
confident that that
is actually true with trained lifters
doing multi-joint exercises
especially if you're interested in the
prime movers so for example if you're
interested in squatting for hamstring
growth
one that's kind of dumb like we've
written about that on the site before
but two if you were doing that you know
maybe it would behoove you to go to
failure on every set
but if you're squatting for quad growth
you know you may not have to actually go
that close to failure to to stimulate
your quads pretty well
um and then the
second assumption there like needing
pretty slow contractile velocities
to achieve full tension on each fiber
i'm pretty skeptical of that and the
reason i'm skeptical of it
is so that's largely based on the load
velocity relationship
or the the force velocity curve where
at um at higher forces velocities lower
at
lower velocities or at lower forces
velocity is higher
but that again is established under
unfatigued conditions
so essentially you know if you're having
a fiber contract against
increasing loads as the loads go up
contraction velocity decreases
but under conditions of fatigue it's
not the exact same relationship under
conditions of fatigue
if velocity is go fatigue with the same
load
just to be clear as velocity is going
down
force is also going down like force and
tension aren't increasing as velocity
decreases
as you do say like a set of 12 to
failure
uh like velocity is going to be lowest
on the last rep before failure
but i don't think you can make the case
that per fiber tension is higher
at that point your fibers have fatigued
there's going to be some metabolites in
there that affect
the interactions between actin and
myosin and
also like central drive is going to
decrease
so um the
the frequency with which uh or the
frequency at which motor units or the
motor nerves can
reach depolarization and send signals to
the fibers
like firing rates that's going to be
lower as well
so i don't think the lower velocities
closer to failure
during a set to failure with a fixed
load indicates higher
tension per fiber i think it indicates
that you can't produce as much tension
per fiber
so if you're using hyper fiber tension
as a
as a reason supporting the effective
reps model
i don't think that you can make that
argument
in the context of a set to failure so
lower velocity is
lower tension in that case not the same
as like the force velocity relationship
with changing loads
when you're fresh so anyway the um
the biggest thing i'm trying to get at
here is that the
mechanistic underpinnings of the
effective reps model
[Music]
they make sense in so far as recruiting
those highest threshold motor units and
exposing them to a fair amount of
tension
those things make sense based on what we
mechanistically know about hypertrophy
but the idea that you necessarily need
to be within five reps of failure to
trigger those things
i'm less sold on i think you can get
pretty close to full motor unit
recruitment
for the prime movers of multi-joint
exercises quite a bit further out from
failure
and i don't actually think
you're maximizing per fiber tension as
you get closer to failure
that doesn't necessarily
[Music]
the evidence in favor of that comes from
studies on the wrong context which is
looking at
unfatigued fibers with different loads
versus
under the influence of fatigue taking
the same load to failure